this this is why i think conservatives
at this point are
really dumb for continuing to support
cops we had that people don't think
conservatives should support cops
absolutely not what do you think they
should do instead they should protest
cops and call for their abolition
we we have do you think conservatives
should call for police police
abolitionists yes 100
with like ilhan omar absolutely 100
i am dying to hear why oh yeah
absolutely um before the elections
and before the coveted lockdowns there's
a good reason to want to have police
i mean crime has been skyrocketing
across you know a bunch of different
cities since the police have been
defunded and demoralized
however after the elections and i've
said this many times when that when the
voters rejected
the position that cops are good and
voted for those who oppose the police
well at that point i say first if you're
a cop staying in this political
environment where they're
gonna lock you up they're gonna put you
in jail well then i'm not gonna defend
you when that time comes because
you decided to stay in the burning
building perhaps you said i'm gonna stay
in to try and save lives okay
i can respect that still i warned you
and said get out while you still can
you know the fire was was coming what
we're seeing now
with coven the police gleefully
sight gave tickets to the jewish
community harassed jews and synagogues
uh padlocked uh uh gates shut so that
you know little spacecraft
couldn't play in playgrounds they they
as you mentioned they weren't enforcing
in new york at that bar owner but the
state police did come and barricade so
cops at this point cops are cops
many conservatives actually started
smack talking police
we saw a ton of conservative
commentators saying that
the cops turned their back on on the
good hard-working small business
and started arresting and fining people
and ticketing people and harassing them
just because they were told to we see
the cops guarding the illegal black
lives matter mural in new york city
bill de blasio had no authorization to
appropriate funds to do that he did that
and 27 cops arrested stood guard and
arrested those who challenged the
illegal actions of the mayor
how could you as a conservative who
likely not not every single person
many who don't live in the big cities
defend corrupt democrat politicians and
the police forces
that are enabling them to keep doing the
illegal things they're doing like
painting big black lives matter murals
and arresting small business owners and
families and shutting down churches
but what police do is what the executive
branch tells them to do that's their job
so the police aren't there to have their
own independent opinion
the police did bill de blasio break the
law
did bill de blasio break the law in
appropriating taxpayer dollars to paint
them to paint that big black lives
matter mural
in front of the trump tower just to be a
jerk right he did
um yeah he did not have a permit so
that means that the police officer and
abetting a crime theft of taxpayer
dollars
i'm sorry i don't care if you're a cop
you break the law you break the law so
you think they should have gone up there
and arrested bill de blasio that's
perhaps true that doesn't
least that should have changed they will
not stand guard in an illegal street
mural
right they probably shouldn't have done
that but they also you want to
primarily have to do what they're told i
mean
that's what they do so i think the mayor
told the cop to rob a bank and the cop
did it he should go to prison
well sure yeah if the mayor steals
public funds
to paint the street and then tells the
gops to guard his illicit
work right the cops are breaking the law
yeah but i also don't think that
destroying the
institution of law enforcement is going
to do anything to to make anything
better
no matter if you see what's going on in
uh in portland
which there's a video andy portland is a
disaster
well so so look there's there's a guy i
don't know who he is i don't know maybe
he did something
all i see is this one video and based on
this one video we see
antifa marching towards a guy who's
backing up with a baseball bat saying
get away i'm warning you
get away i'll come back i'll f you up
get away from me the cops immediately
arrest him
and apologize to antifa well portland is
a mess too
but so why why why are conservatives
defending cops who are doing that
are they defending cops who are doing
that or are they defending the
institution
of police work so what do we what do we
have right now
in terms of these big cities with
cops who have been shutting down
churches who have been defending the
corrupt politicians
and arresting anyone like portland i
understand it's a mess
why defend so okay how about this we'll
get some we'll get specific
abolish the portland police department
well the mayor i think is in charge of
the portland
police department and i think so yeah so
probably they should get rid of that
mayor and get a mayor who knows what
he's doing
i i think the responsibilities of the
individual
the individual police officers sure and
they are leaving the forces in droves
and they're going places where
i think christie noam put out a thing
saying like we're hiring police officers
um i think there's some hiring going on
in dallas
you know these officers who are leaving
these big blue cities are finding work
elsewhere and i think it makes sense for
them to do that
but i don't think that it makes sense to
completely
say that you know law enforcement itself
should be abolished
in florida you can own guns
sure in west virginia guns wyoming guns
texas interestingly texas has some
pretty serious laws but
in new york you can own illegal guns
without any real
impunity in chicago uh you basically
can't
in maryland and new jersey you basically
can't you can own long guns
handguns they just have insane
restrictions and it's the police that
are going to be the ones to take away
your constitutional right
so well they're going to enforce it
they're going to enforce that law
yeah if a law passes it'd be
unconstitutional for sure
so why would a cop who sworn off the
constitution say well you know my
corrupt boss told me to arrest you so
you're under arrest
are cops sworn to protect the
constitution i thought that was the
judiciary that's the police the police
were not the constitution
really yes they do that's interesting
and they don't uphold it
so i think about red states well they
don't they uphold the law
right and then if the law is challenged
they would uphold the law that was
remade
there there's interesting arguments i
understand uh i i think we need police
but
here's what i'm saying maybe we should
say abolished blue state police
you look at the red states that have
been doing a really good job with covid
not arresting people for running their
businesses allowing things to remain
open and and tactfully
and guaran a lot of constitutional carry
laws being passed so now i think it's
like iowa or utah whatever
uh taxes is about to pass it as well
yeah i saw that uh west virginia
already has it i look at these red
states and i'm like the cops they're
doing a fantastic job
and they've got and there's better
leadership not perfect and you look at
these blue states and the cops are
enforcing
the most insane interpretation defending
antifa
they're not being prosecuted you you if
you accidentally cross the bridge from
philly into new jersey with a handgun
that's a fail then you're really in
trouble and why and a cop would actually
lock you up for this
but don't you think that's a question of
leadership i mean the police are
the police are there to they basically
do what they're told
that's bad yeah well that's just doing
my job what it is that's
really really bad i'm not saying that's
good or bad i'm saying that is their
function
that's the same thing is the true with
the you know with the military
do we want a situation right and so
here's the question
do you want a situation where the
enforcement branch
of the executive arm of government
uh is going against that executive arm
of government do we want that branch of
government to just be split in half like
that
do we want law enforcement saying uh
i know that you're supposed to tell me
what to do and that's your job and my
job is to do what i'm told
and we're not going to do that anymore
do we want the army to stand up to the
president and say we're not going to do
what you tell us yes
we we want that we absolutely do yeah if
the president said do something illegal
and we it's actually
by law they have to say no isn't that
where we start landing into
like uh you know military coup type of
situation
i think that's i think that that's a
dangerous thing well if the president
gives an illegal order
there by by law they have to say no
the police swore off the constitution
and still are willing to uphold i think
this is all
activities yeah i mean i think it's a
real problem to say that
we want the police force to stand up on
its own hind legs
and you know start marching around the
farm yard and telling the other animals
stretch to say that versus cops should
reject illegal orders
probably they should reject illegal
orders but you know
why should i support them i don't know i
don't know i mean listen
i live in brooklyn new york and if we
don't have police officers
we're going to have an even worse
situation than we have now but didn't
you already say the cops are nowhere to
be seen
and they're not i don't see them i don't
see them around they're not enforcing
covet orders
so it sounds like they're doing good i'm
happy that they're not enforcing that
i should say not enforcing the
unconstitutional things i i guess the
issue i have right now is it seems like
a lot of the arguments for police are
coming from urban conservatives which
are few and far between relative to
rural conservatives
right there's like five of us and we
have dinner a couple times so
yeah for me i'm kind of like we don't
have cops out here
but i'm allowed to have you know to an
extent weapons
because we're actually in maryland we're
on the border so uh
in west virginia you can literally walk
around with a barrett you know
m82 if you want to it's really heavy and
probably ridiculous but you could
and i wonder why it is that in these you
know
i wouldn't call them dense but there
there are there are communities that
have you have next door neighbors like
literally 10 feet from your house just
like any other urban community why is
there why is there no
won't be breaking in any of these houses
and there's no cops
and why is it that new york city you've
got democrats these activists
complaining about the cops
but it's the few it's the 20 of new york
that's conservative defending them
meanwhile also getting abused by them
but i just don't see any legitimate
arguments the democrats in new york city
who are calling for
getting rid of police they don't
actually mean what they're saying
right like the park slope democrats
don't mean
uh you know get the police out of park
slope they don't mean that at all
they mean they say it what are they
saying they say like defund police
well then but that's not what they do we
can't read their minds yeah no we can't
read their minds but you know what
they're saying they're saying
police are racist and get them out of
the black communities um and then the
police leave the black communities
and crime goes up and more more people
get killed but
we shouldn't assume that you know when
we see people in this community saying
get the
cops out of here i think we should say
okay that's your community not mine
yeah but that's because you live out
here and i'm like i'm from the south
side of chicago
so i'd love to have in this house
outside of chicago been able to bear
arms
to defend myself from the gang violence
instead after getting shot at it i'm
like i probably shouldn't live here
anymore
because well because you can't really
have a gun there but you know the gang
members can
because you know because they get them
illegally right
this is kind of what i was saying but
the cops would arrest me if i
tried to do anything about it in new
york city we had giuliani who came in
and really started trying to clean up
the city in what like 92.
and i remember it very distinctly
because it got a lot harder to buy drugs
in washington square park we had to like
go down the lower east side to do that
um and we you know
we made it work we figured out a work
but uh
so giuliani really did an awful lot to
clamp down on crime in the city
manhattan got
a lot safer and it was actually pretty
remarkable
and then when julian when bloomberg came
in
he took this gift of a really safe
manhattan
and he used that to create basically a
playground for the wealthy
and then bolster the outer boroughs so
the outer boroughs got a lot safer too
he got slammed for this you know broken
windows policing thing
but that was actually rather effective
policy and the entire city
got drastically more safe it's just too
authoritarian for me
well it was actually i mean it was
pretty magical to be able to like walk
around manhattan
at four o'clock in the morning with
absolutely no fear for your safety
what a year and two months ago did they
have guns banned back then
i really don't know i never had to i've
i never looked into owning a gun in new
york city until
maybe like a month or so ago do you ever
hear the story about the uh the black
cop who started giving out tickets in
central park
no i could be getting the story wrong
but it was basically uh
black cop shows up in central park
handing out tickets to couples sitting
down in a picnic with wine
public public drinking is a is a petty
offense here's your your fine your
summons or whatever
well the reason he did it i guess was
because the cops would go to the black
neighborhood start giving out tickets to
people drinking 40s on their stew
sure so he said you want to come to my
neighborhood i'm going to go to central
park and do the same thing the cop got
in trouble
got reprimanded so these these these big
cities
that have been been run by democrats for
for generations
have these problems with asymmetrical
enforcement and i think it's
poverty is a big component of it less so
race but i do think race plays a role
why should i defend these cops when the
democrats are the ones complaining about
them
and they're willing to enforce
unconstitutional laws and i don't live
there
so sure 20 of the people who live there
are conservative
and defending cops meanwhile they're the
ones being locked down by the cops
and the cops are defending antifun
protecting them or at the very least
when they do arrest them the da's cut
them loose
then when a conservative gets arrested
they get the book thrown at them the
cops are willing to say i'm being
neutral by arresting the both of you
and the da says good job auntie foy
you're free to go conservative welcome
to jail
i don't know the protests that i went to
um this year
in union square and around new york city
i saw maybe like
a couple of times somebody got arrested
and usually it was one of the protesters
and most of the time what i saw were
cops you know the protesters would come
up to them and say you guys are pigs and
all of this stuff
and the cops would just applaud them and
say oh you're so brave so courageous and
they're so brave
no they were they were making fun of
them right right but you remember when
the cops kept a knee for the for the
protesters
yes i do remember that that's really
good for conservatives that happened in
brooklyn i thought that was a horror
show in fact
and i don't i don't see yourself in
opposition to that in fact yeah so
so i think conservatives are unwilling
to stand up for themselves
and that's part of the problem i think
this is a very dangerous game though
i think defunding police no matter what
side you're on saying that we do not
need
uh law enforcement have you tried to buy
a gun in new york city well
like it's like several weeks you need an
interview you need to give them a reason
why you need to buy a gun
you can't you've got an authoritarianism
problem well that is an authoritarian
problem yeah yeah i agree
so but i think that it's a you know it's
a dangerous
i hear what you're saying about you know
police not upholding their duty i think
it's a very dangerous road to go down to
say that we don't need police at all
because they are ineffectual
again it's a it's it's it's destroying
something without building anything in
its place
i'm not saying i i do build a framework
first yeah i do
the problem is when what's happening is
that cops will
without hesitation arrest moderates and
conservatives
or even some in some instances as
liberals especially if they're if
they're
upholding their second amendment rights
in a city with skyrocketing gun violence
and crime
i'm like well that's kind of a problem
then because they can't keep a control
they can't keep control of the crime but
they're absolutely willing to arrest
law-abiding citizens who get scared and
want to buy something to defend
themselves
i'll check that out i haven't seen those
cases and i'll take a look at dalton
people getting arrested for having guns
people getting arrested in new york for
having
happens all the time illegal guns
for having yeah because they're all
illegal well they're not all illegal
like you you you're just
gonna get into this you're my house if
you go to the cvs near my house
you can hear a lot of gunfire it's kind
of jarring so
it's downstairs illegal illegal guns are
what people have in places like new york
because you need a qualifying reason to
actually
get a gun right but illegal guns are
also what are shooting little babies at
barbecues
in the middle of bed stuy yeah because
criminals commit crimes right the cops
stop it can they yeah i mean there
should be i think better gun laws in new
york once i looked into it i was
actually really shocked to find how
difficult it would be
to get any kind of weapon so less gun
laws i think the
i think the gun laws should not be quite
so strict at all i think most
conservatives don't live in big cities
that are run by democrats and i think
it's silly
to support the broken and
unconstitutional systems propped up by
democrats
when you don't live there and then just
it makes no sense to me at this point
now before the election i was absolutely
like yeah these people are crazy do you
found the police as nuts
and then when the people in these cities
all voted to defund their police and
support democrats i'm like
that's insane too i certainly didn't
vote to defund the police
did you see what happened in minneapolis
that went really badly
they defunded police seattle defunded
police they voted for it they voted for
it
and so the people should if look i lived
in new york for like five or six years
and there were serious problems with
crime and uh i lived on the street where
the two cops got executed by the black
nationalists yeah i remember that so i
was like um
you know going to leave so i moved over
i jumped i jumped the river to the
jersey side
and then someone planted bombs in
manhattan and in jersey city and i was
like
i'm gonna move maybe away from these
cities they can't
stop the violence and the crime right
but they also but they can stop you from
defending yourself as a law abiding
citizen
they can stop you from getting a gun
because they have really harsh gun
control laws
that don't work yeah that don't actually
keep illegal guns off the street and
who's enforcing that
oh i the police i'm sure it's the police
absolutely but i don't think it makes
sense to
take it away without building something
in its place we can't have a situation
where there's no police in new york city
that's just a that's just a horrifying
idea
but already we're looking at it right
we're looking at
so we had votes to defund the police i
think bloomberg took a bunch of money
away from police and
gave it to prostitutes or something like
that i mean something really stupid
um social workers are supposed to show
up now at calls or whatever else
but i don't think that we can just
destroy it and take it away
if there's nothing in its place we've
already seen so much violent crime
increase
and a lot of that is because the police
have been you know pushed aside and
dropped away i think if you talk the
police
talk to the police commissioner at this
point um you know
he's not in favor of any of this stuff
either so
sure like are the police doing a bad job
yes does that mean we need to get rid of
the police no
it also doesn't mean we need to reform
them in the way that the leftists are
saying we need to reform them because
that's not effective either
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you